Warning, this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
Hey everybody, welcome to LED Live.
Today's topic is a hot topic and I don't
believe it's talked about enough in our
church. So, it's going to come with a
warning. If you have small children, you
might want to watch this first before
you share with them. But, we're going to
talk about sexuality. A lot of young
kids are exposed way too early. How does
it affect your identity? Find out on
this episode of LED Live.
Lights exposing darkness. As we get into
this topic here, I'm very excited to
introduce our guests on today's show. We
have two special guests, Kezia and
Michael Carducci. Michael's been on our
show before, so you might have seen him.
But, uh thank you guys for coming on and
uh you know, this is a topic that's near
and dear to my heart. I have small
children and uh you know, this is a
topic that my wife and I actually talk
about a lot. When is it time to bring
these topics up to our kids and you
know, definitely
early sexual exposure can really set you
on a course for your whole life.
Yeah. And I'm sure as we get into your
your your testimony about this, uh we're
going to see exactly what kind of damage
that can do. But, uh also God is a
redeeming God and how he can flip that
around for his glory.
So, uh welcome to the show and tell us a
little bit about this topic.
Yeah, so sexuality is definitely
something that everyone deals with as we
know. Um I know for myself, it was one
thing that I didn't think was a big
issue. I just thought everyone dealt
with their own sexualities at any time
in the age. So, it wasn't really until I
had gone to Cuba on a trip and I came
across Mike where I was then realizing
that what I was going through um with
the bisexuality, um pornography
addiction that it was actually a big
issue of mine. Um so, that's what we're
going to really get into today.
Michael's with Coming Out Ministries and
you went you were dealing with this
sexuality thing and you went to one of
his ministry. Like what was that?
were on a it was a mission trip. Um
everyone was able to come in. Uh we were
in Cuba at that time. And so, there were
about 18 people on this trip. And um
Coming Out Ministries, two of the
colleagues were also there. I was there
with just as a general um
missionary. Just being there as well.
And so, I knew what I was going through,
but I didn't think it really made that
much of a difference um even though I
knew I was serving God um primarily
because it wasn't something that was
really spoken about in church. And so,
for me to be on that trip to see how God
was really working things out um one
morning, cuz we would come together have
morning devotions. And then I remember
at one point, Mike had shared for him
that pornography was his best friend.
That anytime he was feeling like lonely,
tired, or angry, that he would turn to
it. So, being that we were having
devotion outside, um the sun was
shining, I had my sunglasses on, and I
started to tear up because I was like,
wait, this is actually an issue of mine.
And so, that's where I really saw that I
have to get help. Um but, there were a
lot of things that had happened on that
trip for me to really see that I had an
issue.
you were such a master of disguise cuz
you would have those dark glasses on and
she would sit there stoically and you
were such a a dynamo on that trip
because it it was probably one of the
most spiritual trips I've ever been on.
We were so united and the translators
that were with us and and and the people
were just in such great need financially
and spiritually and we would have these
two-hour worships in the morning and
Kezia was like one of the main speakers
and she was talking about the sanctuary.
And so, I hadn't have a clue and those
glasses
they help they they hid a multitude of
what was going on inside her head. I had
no idea you were even affected by that.
Yeah, it was it was a lot.
So, wait, you were preaching on the
sanctuary. Mhm, yeah, we were it was a
different church every night.
Yeah, it's a different church um cuz it
was a group of us um that we would we
were all assigned different topics to
touch on. So, sometimes it's like, you
know, um who are we in Christ? Um Christ
and marriage. Um another thing was like
sanctuary. So, it just so happened to be
that I had to speak on the sanctuary.
So, when I was speaking on that, it
really touched me because I'm coming
from a construction background. And so,
I knew that anytime builders or
architects, they wanted a building
built, there was a lot of detail behind
it. It took years to build. So, to see
how God was really specific with the
details, um with the materials, the
dimensions he wanted, it really showed
me how much more he wanted to restore
his image um his image um within me. And
how important that message really truly
is. I mean, there is there is you know,
this was God's plan to to solve the sin
problem. You know what I mean? So, it's
like the like the blueprint, if you
would, for for humanity and and you
know, our need of of bringing our sins
to him, laying them on the altar,
realizing that we need another
substitute for those. I mean, those are
deep deep concepts. So, you're preaching
this message, which is literally how God
can like solve sin in your life.
And yet behind the scenes, you're you're
totally engaging in other things.
Yeah, definitely. Um it was pornography,
masturbation. Um there was a bisexuality
aspect of things, the sexual addiction
that was going on. So, I knew at some
point there were other things I was also
doing when it came to drinking, smoking,
um smoking weed. Um there was a lot of
depression I had going on, the suicidal
thoughts primarily from teenage years.
There was a lot going on when my parents
divorced, me trying to figure out, you
know, who am I coming from a biracial
home. So, there was a lot of things. God
was not the center of the household. Um
so, even though
a time came when I finally accepted
Christ, some of those things went away.
But, it when it came to the sexuality
aspect, that had to be the hardest thing
to let go of. I didn't think it was
possible. So, even for me to be able to
be here now to speak on that, it's a
miracle of its own. You you know why I
absolutely love this topic is because
look at look at what God has done,
right? He gives us this beautiful thing
called sexuality that's meant to just
interlink us together so that it's not
broken. You know what I mean? Bonds you
together and the devil's just twisted
that and that's why the addiction side
of pornography is incredibly difficult
to get rid of because God created that
bond. We're just bonding with something
that is not holy or you know, that is
that is basically outside of what God
intended.
because that has been so twisted in
church culture that, you know, kids are
told, oh no, sex is filthy, it's dirty,
it's disgusting. When really, God was
the inventor of full-blown intimacy and
his desire is for us to be able to
experience. It was given to us as a
gift. And how sad now because I think
that especially when I hear Kezia's
story is that the church has done a huge
um um mistake in not talking about God's
intention of intimacy and his intention
of sexuality and how that's to be
expressed because when I met Kezia and
realized what she was going through, I
was shocked that there's so little
education in our church when the world
is being educated through YouTube and
and videos about current uh sexuality.
So, why do you think that is? Have you
thought about that?
I think it's because the church refuses
to talk about it. Or it's just such an
uncomfortable thing to to talk about.
But now, you know, if there can be
anything positive about the whole sexual
explosion that's in the world today is
the fact that now we don't have the
luxury to be silent on this anymore. We
have to talk about it.
just about to say that. I was I was
going to say it's a sensitive topic that
you don't want to have to bring up too
early, but you're going to have to beat
the punch with the media. I I think that
is the main problem is I think
for all good intents purposes, the
church is saying we don't want to
overexpose somebody to something. But,
the reality of it is, what is it? First
grade, second grade that people get
exposed to sexual things. I mean, I'm
I'm sure we're going to start back from
the beginning and get into how you got
here. Um but, it's earlier than
everybody thinks. And by the time they
go, oh wow, we need to have
conversations with this when they're
teenagers and they can they can handle
the content. It's like they've already
had five years of their heads filled
with nonsense about it and you're
playing catch-up. So, that's why we want
like, you know, to educate the parents,
educate the church members, inspire
them. You guys got to get get get get up
to speed with this and and help our
church members out because they could be
around preaching preachers dealing with
this. And all of a sudden 62% of
Christian pastors are addicted to porn.
Scotty, the most shocking statistic that
I have is according to Covenant Eyes
that 3% of boys and 17% of girls have
never seen pornography. That in itself
just blew me out of the water. See, I
always heard 99% of males deal with
pornography and the other 1% lie. So,
it's like
Yeah, I I think it's accountability more
than anything. I think it's hush-hush
because it's such a intimate thing that
if it's talked about more and more
people kind of reveal what they're going
through, we're going to have to like
take responsibility and there's going to
have to be um yeah, a form of of
accountability. And I think um a lot of
people may not want to talk about it
because they want to stay within that
sin. If it's not being talked about, I
can keep doing what I'm doing because
it's not being addressed. Okay, so I
want to hear all the way back.
Start back. Let's let's get into this.
Yeah, um so,
my mom uh is Filipino and so, my dad's
Guyanese. So, automatically from a young
age, I just knew I was totally
different. You know, mom, light skin,
straight hair. My father, black, kinky
hair. And so, already I knew that there
was something different from me,
especially with mom just being the
woman, the girl. I'm the girl. I'm
supposed like, you know, be like her,
look like her. Um so, that was a little
different. Um so, automatically having
that difference just in the facade um
and especially being growing up in
Brooklyn, New York, interracial
marriages weren't necessarily that big
at that time. and so majority of the
schools I would go to public schools
were um predominantly black Caribbean
schools, and so when it came to that
Asian side of me, I wasn't really big on
it. I wasn't really promoting it cuz I
was kind of embarrassed by it. Um a lot
of times I would just pray like, you
know, Lord, just make me yellow. Um so
there was already this just feeling
ashamed just of who I was um and just
thinking that, okay, I'm going to be
yellow one day, but that never occurred
up clearly. Um so by the time public
school came about, I ended up having my
first sexual encounter with another
girl.
Um so I just thought that, you know,
everyone did this. This wasn't really
taught at home that if something like
this happened, say something if someone
touches you. And so I thought that's
this was okay.
So was this person older than you? Good
question. I
I don't even remember. I just remember
her being a little bit bigger than me.
Um we were in our uniforms, and so I I
know she wasn't like a fifth grader or
anything, but I just know she was
several just a few years older than me.
Where did it happen? At school. Public
school in the bathroom. Just I remember
just school. Yeah, at school, public
school, just going to I had to use the
bathroom. She was there.
And then it just happened.
And you brought up a great point that
that wasn't discussed in the home you
were like
um there was no instruction given if
such thing happens, this is how you
should respond. We're putting a lot of
um
uh respons- well, not responsibility,
like uh
what is it called? Blame. You're putting
a lot of blame on the church, and of
course the church has a part to play,
but it's the home, the nucleus.
to happen in the home, but I also think
that if it's not getting done in the
home, the church definitely should be
prepared to help, you know, guide that
discussion if the parents aren't willing
or able to have that discussion. But but
I agree, it should happen in the home
first.
And you said public school, do you mind
saying like which grade? Like how young
you were?
I think like first grade, first grade or
so.
Yeah.
It was It was a young time, yeah. I got
a kid in first grade, you know? I mean,
luckily he's pretty clueless, I think.
Well, here's the thing, like we don't
have You don't have to be so detailed in
giving warning to a child, right? If If
someone touches you in these parts, let
me know. And you don't have to get all
detailed and We've had conversations
with that, and and we do check in with
our kids all the time and ask them, you
know, like, has anything ever been
Anybody ever said something that makes
you uncomfortable or nervous? And you
know, that I I think that they would
tell us. I believe so.
And it's important to have that
environment, to have that open
communication with kids.
But what's crazy is people think like,
oh, well, if you send your kids over to
someone's house, this could happen at a
house. This happened at a school. It
happens anywhere, yeah. Right.
It's very unfortunate what could happen.
Cuz from when that hook had occurred, um
I didn't think anything of it. I didn't
tell my mom or dad. I just thought,
okay, you know, it's another form of
play, I guess, in a sense. Didn't think
anything of it. You know, your body
starts to feel a little something. And
so I didn't know that that starting um
really began a path that I could no
longer stop. Of course, until years
later. Um but it was one of those things
when that started, it just really opened
up something that I was unable to
control. Because later on, years down
the line, um
by the age about nine. This was in like
daycare. Um we were supposed to have our
nap time, and so they had grouped us
like with the girls with the girls, cuz
you know, you don't think anything of
it. Just the girls with the girls, boys
with boys. Um the older girls are with
the um
you know, with each other. And so at
that point, we were supposed to be
taking a nap, but we ended up just
fondling each other, just touching each
other. So this was another experience of
mine where it's now it's in a kind of a
group setting. Um just a bunch of girls,
group setting. And so I'm just thinking
when I think of sex now, I'm just
thinking with girls, group setting, this
is okay. Um so That sort of sets the
stage for even what you're what you're
excited about, you know what I mean?
It's like kind of like that that that
That's why I think like um hearing about
how the mind works and we imprint those
sexual experiences on our mind, and then
we try to recreate them. So when
something like that happens to you, then
you're trying to recreate that same kind
of experience down the road.
the thing. It's like one of the things I
was learning was that if sex does not
occur the same way I had it at first,
it's what's the word? It's not as
exciting. Yeah, it's not as exciting as
the first time. So of course, now years
later, I'm trying to repeat that over
time and realizing that this is contrary
to what God desires. And that had to be
the hardest thing to break off because
for the longest I'm just thinking, even
when I get married, I desire to have a
female in there as well. And it wasn't
through counseling, you know, through
prayer and realizing that, you know,
this is not God's design. If it was, he
would have written it in Genesis.
Because it took me a while, a few years
to really recognize that this is not
God's desire for us.
And and you kind of separate that world,
you know, even though you obviously were
Christian at some point in time. It's
like you kind of have that life over
here, and then you have the
When the When the doors close, you know,
it's like all bets off, right? Just to
understand correctly, this thing that
happened in the bathroom, the girl
probably just kind of
maybe took advantage or whatever, but
like in the in the nap time, it was
multiple kids, right? Yeah. So all these
kids had to have some kind of exposure
or something.
That's kind of shocking. It is cuz that
was something that, like I said, I I
didn't think this was anything wrong.
It's just another setting up. Okay, you
know, Yeah, especially when there's more
people doing it, it seems more
acceptable. Yeah, and I didn't say
anything at that time, either. I just
said, okay, it happened. So first time I
never said anything. Second time
occurred, never said anything. And then
in the midst of that, I don't remember
when, but I know pornography and
masturbation came into the picture. Um
so this is before I'm 10. Just having
that already starting at such a young
age.
Now, uh you're quite young, so
probably the internet was easily
accessible, right? AOL dial-up.
I remember that.
Right, right, right. No pictures to
load, one layer at a time. So I I I want
to ask this question because I I want
parents to be able to see where some of
these dark corners of your house can be.
Where How did you get a hold of the
pornography? I mean, one of the things
is I don't remember specifically how it
started, but I I do know I recall
because my parents divorced when I was
about 11, 12. And so this was a way
before my parents divorced because I
remember my dad was still there. We had
the computer in um in their bedroom, and
so I would just go and watch it when I
knew they weren't home. And, you know,
sometimes I was really active on like
the the chat the chat rooms, just trying
to get anything um just trying to figure
out anything, talking to people
secretly. So it was just accessible, but
I don't remember the the very first
first time, but I know before my parents
divorced I was really active in it, just
sneaking around, trying to get to it.
Yeah. Isn't it incredible or like
across-the-board
moral compass? Like you you didn't grow
up in a Christian Christian home or
anything like that, but you felt the
need to hide this, do it in secret. Like
it's It's interesting. If you're doing
things that you you can't do out in the
open. Now, I'm not suggesting that, you
know, married couple should do those
married things out in the open, but
yeah, if if there's some level of of I
need to be secret and I can't tell
anybody about this, that's where sin can
really thrive, you you know? For sure.
It really wasn't until when my
parents divorced that that's when things
really went south. Um And that was at
12, right?
Yeah, I was 12. So that's before the
real teen year.
So when my dad left, um that was really
devastating. I just remember him, you
know, packing his bags, and then I'm
like downstairs where we were living,
and just like having to just say goodbye
to him. But it was one of those things
where I was just like, why do you have
to go? Um and so that was the hardest
thing for me to now have to live this
new life with my mom, who I was still
having, you know, I loved her, but at
the same time realizing that there was
still that hatred because it was like I
didn't I didn't look like you. There was
this difference. Um cuz I remember it
specifically like middle school, I had
to go to It was the first day of school,
and um we were in a We would have the
students come together in the
schoolyard. And I remember mom and dad
were walking me to school, and in the
the middle school I was going to, it's
predominantly a predominantly a
Caribbean school. And so there were like
few Asians there, and I remember just
telling my mom, you can let go of my
hand because you're yellow and I'm
black. So it was one of those things
where
that?
Yeah, it was like one of those things
where I I wasn't fully happy with who I
was because I felt like I had to pick
one side. And so there was this level of
like eeny meeny miny moe, you know, I
have to be one side. I can't be Filipino
and Guyanese um because of the the
environment I was in.
Do you mind um sharing her response to
that since you actually verbalized it? I
remember at that time, it was kind of
like a shocker, but I remember
specifically when I got home from school
cuz they you know, dropping me off to
the schoolyard, um my mom, she was like
crying the whole day. And I didn't
realize the effect of it. You know,
you're you're just young. You're just
thinking, pick one side cuz I didn't
think it was possible to just be, you
know, to be both. It's it's totally
fine. That's how God created me. Um but
because of where I was in school,
majority of my, you know, classmates,
they're Caribbean, black, or Dominican,
Chinese. Like we have like like really a
small amount of Asian students.
So for me, I'm just thinking, Kizzia,
you have to be one. That's it. Just one.
Can't be both. So that Having that
foundation of just struggling, you know,
God is not really in my life, that's
really what allowed other things to now
come about. When dad was leaving, it's
like, okay, I can't be black anymore.
Like what do I do? I'm with this Asian
woman. I'm filled with a lot of just
hatred. Just I'm filled with a lot of
frustration. There's anger coming about
because now it's like dad is leaving.
You know, my dad was He was a big
advocate in education. So with him now
leaving, it came to a point when school
for me was really nothing. Um I became
very careless in school. And so having
to now deal with um dad leaving, mom,
she's trying to figure out, you know,
how does she now live this new life as a
single mother, which was really
understanding at that time. I wasn't
understanding of that. It was just like,
ah, I don't like you. Um now I'm
understanding of what she had to go
through. But to see, you know, she's
trying to figure out her new life,
trying to figure out, you know, why did
my husband leave me? Um the man who has
now left her, uh she's left with the
daughter who looks like that man. So
there's a lot of things she's trying to
work through. She's pouring out her
anger on me, which was understandable.
Now I understand that. But at that time,
you know, I'm filled with my own pain.
So I'm going to anything just trying to
fill that the void, the pain, I'm just
having some sort of an outlet. So that's
when pornography, masturbation really
became more heightened, becoming more
promiscuous now with both guys and
girls.
The depression was really big. My level
of anger where I just wanted both of my
parents dead because I was just like I I
don't care. You both are, you know,
doing your own thing. You're going
through the divorce. What am I supposed
to do now as an only child? And so there
was a suicidal thoughts coming about.
It's like I want both of them dead, but
I also want myself to die as well. And
so there was like the partying going on,
the drinking, the smoking, the smoking
the weed, just anything to really This
is the teenage years. This was just
Yeah,
yeah, predominantly my teenage years.
That's what I know my teenage years to
be. So just recognize that I was just
doing anything to just really numb to
numb my to numb the feelings I was going
through. Why I asked you that question
is because that would have been the
perfect time for your mother to have a
conversation with you as you expressed
yourself in that way. I think
sometimes parents may miss obvious
clues. Like the kid will I feel like
will tell you when they're ready or when
they're open. And especially I mean kids
have no filter at all. They'll just
blurt out stuff and it's really the
parents' response that will really make
or break that that child. How fortunate
because if a parent can put their own
feelings aside long enough to realize
that the kid is giving you a clue. It's
not a personal attack, but your mother
could have used that as an opportunity
to express the differences and
what I really find fascinating about
your story Kezia is that you were an
only child. So if you had brothers and
sisters, then you would have been able
to look at them and know who you were as
well, but you really didn't have that.
The only people you had to compare
yourself to was your your black father
that you look like or your Asian mother
that you didn't look like. Did your
relationship with your father continue
after he left?
It was really sporadic. So you know,
he's began his new life and so I'm just
here like what am I supposed to do now?
You know, mom's doing her own thing, but
with my dad it was very sporadic. We'll
catch up here and there. It wasn't
consistent though.
Which also probably feeds into that like
well that's that's what men are like.
Precisely. And then I'm going to go for
the women, you know, it's like
so so you you started getting into
partying. You started getting Were were
you engaging in like lots of promiscuous
activity?
for sure. It was a sneaking out.
Sometimes I remember before school
school school would start like around I
feel like 8:00 in the morning, but
sometimes like I remember when my mom
would leave she would go to work early
and then I would go sneak out to some
guy's house or girls whoever before
school would start. So I was just trying
to feed that addiction anywhere. Yeah,
like you didn't really think of anything
at that time, but now I think about it
I'm like oh, I would never do that.
But back to that
That's pretty No, no, that's pretty much
a sign of a sexual addict.
Yeah, like now I look back at it I'm
like Kezia, you were a hot mess. Like
what were you doing? It's not just
promiscuity. It's addiction. Just
feeding it. Just yeah. It's trying to
fill a god-sized hole in your heart,
you know? It was a lot because like now
that I look back into it just to see
what would go on in a span of a week,
the amount of partners I would have in
between trying to, you know, be
consistent in school. I remember I was
like in an orchestra. So after homework,
you know, after school I'd have
orchestra. So you know, you have this
facade of acting like, you know,
everything's okay, but really deep down
just being so broken and questioning
like, you know, when am I going to die?
Cuz I just want the pain to end. So
that's where it was just having to
recognize that I I didn't know what I
was doing. I didn't have any guidance.
And even in the midst of all that I was
doing, I remember specifically
especially when I was very active
sexually active, I would always ask God,
Lord, just make sure I don't get
pregnant or have any STDs. Because I
knew for me if if I were to get
pregnant, my plan was to have an
abortion. I was like no doubt about it,
abortion. I don't care. That was it.
We did a show on abortion and this is
this is really an interesting topic, but
I really honestly believe that like you
okay, you're you're in high school. So
you're what? 14?
Yeah, 14 between 17 and older.
15, 16, 17, right? And look at the
decision that was made. Immediately this
is what would happen if I was pregnant.
That decision was already made. And so
when that pregnancy pops up, that
decision's already made. And what was
the what was the age limit that they put
on that movie? It was like 17.
Yes, you have to be 18 or older. So 17
and older.
18 and older, the decision's already
made. Right there. And and that's why
man, it's like we got to talk about
this. Talking about Unplanned. Have you
seen that movie? No. PureFlix? Not not
yet. That's on my to-do list. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. If you haven't
If you haven't seen Unplanned, you need
to go and watch that movie. If you have
young kids, honestly 13, 14, they're
they're talking about sexual issues.
Show them that thing so that they can
actually make a conscious decision
before the problem arises.
Can can I also interject here that as a
a sexual
a history of sexual addiction, for me
every time that I would connect sexually
with somebody was an affirmation of some
little type of value.
Is it the same for you? It's like oh, I
need I need my mother just left. My
dad's not around and so I need somebody
to validate me. If you find me sexually
desirable even if you just use me and it
only lasts 10, 15 minutes or whatever, I
got the validation that I need. Now I
can go to gym class, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. For sure cuz it was one of those
things where I recognized at that time
it was being able to receive some sort
of love even if it was bad. If I'm
receiving something even if it's bad,
even if it's a counterfeit, I didn't
care as long it was filling that need at
that time.
How did you hold it all together? Cuz
when I met you in Cuba, you looked like
you were complete package. You you were
like this devoted Christian and that you
were like a preacher or whatever and
then to come from such a
from such a conflicted past like how
were you sorting it all together and
even just moving through the day and
thinking that that was um
that that was like the truest expression
of your Christian life. That's really
difficult for me to understand. For me
it was either one or the other and you
just blurred both of them.
I mean it just goes to show the level of
the addiction, the the struggle that I
know for sure I was going through.
Because when it came to letting go of
smoking weed, letting go of the
drinking, the partying,
that was a little bit easier to let go
of. When I first accepted Christ, that
was easy. But when it came to the sexual
addiction, even like after from the time
I had said yes to Christ and then time
from Cuba, I think that was about 6, 7
years of span. The sexual addiction, the
pornography, the masturbation, that
didn't quite end. Like I had I tried and
I was under the impression that, you
know, you would speak your testimony,
you you know, in Revelation it talks
about, you know, you overcome by the
blood of the lamb and the word of your
testimony. So I was under the impression
if I said my testimony that I've
overcome it, I've done the work, I'm
good. But failing to realize there was a
amount of work I had to do in
maintaining that victory. So even when
you had met me in Cuba, it was one of
those things where I'm trying to balance
God, I'm still trying to hold on to my
my addictions,
but it was a struggle. It was a fight of
course cuz it's two different spirits
I'm trying to work with. So are you
going to church when you're in high
school? I would just go when I had time
cuz majority of my like if I would go to
church, it would just be for friends and
I would go on Saturdays like after a
riding class. So my Saturdays tended to
be for like school activities and then
afterwards I'd go to church sometimes
just to meet up with friends.
And so you're kind of one foot sort of
kind of getting into it. Was there an
actual conversion
point where you
really started going seriously to
church? It was at one point when so it
was one evening a Saturday night I had
gone to church during the day
and this is just like a sometimes I
would go to church sometimes for friends
or just maybe there was a program going
on, but it wasn't really anything
intimate that I was personally desiring.
So it wasn't until this one Saturday
evening I was really stressed out about
something going on and so I figured, you
know what, I'll just smoke and get high
and just, you know, just numb the pains,
the things I was going through. And so I
reached out to a friend and we had
smoked, but then things didn't go as
planned where I ended up getting so high
where rather we were both so high that
we ended up having sex with each other.
So it was one of those things where I
was frustrated because that wasn't the
plan. The plan was just to smoke, just
get high, leave it alone.
But but because I knew I had to go to
work the following day, I tried to go to
sleep, but I wasn't really able to go to
sleep. And so
I had gone to work
and because I was a lifeguard at that
time, no one was coming into the pool.
So I figured, you know what, perfect.
I'll take a little nap
no one would see me.
I was just like I'm just going to take a
nap, catch up for my sleep. So I went to
sleep and I had a dream where I saw
myself getting rebaptized because when I
was 12
I had I got baptized just because like
there were some people just coming in
from the church. They said, you know,
are you interested in, you know, Jesus
Christ? So I just did it just because I
was like okay, whatever, no big deal.
But God like I had mentioned was really
nothing to me. I just viewed him as a
genie that he could just answer, you
know, my requests and I'll be good to
go. But it wasn't really until that time
where I had that dream and seeing myself
getting rebaptized where I was just kind
of like in shock of what I knew I did
last night and now God's here like, you
know, don't worry about that. I'm here
to help you even though you feel like
you're at your lowest point. Because
that was really a low point for me
because I was really frustrated that,
you know, beside the fact, you know,
smoking the weed, it was also now I'm
being intimate with this person that I
had zero plans in doing that with. And
so I was really frustrated with myself.
So, to see how God was able to work in
that moment, in that dream, that's when
things really started where I said, "All
right, this is the last time I'm going
to smoke the weed." When it came to the
sex part, I was I was I didn't know.
Yeah. You're like, "We'll deal with that
later.
Baby steps, baby steps. So, like
yeah, baby steps for sure. I I like that
even in your darkness, that Jesus was
still there for you. And and to know
that even though you you felt guilt and
and and you were convicted by, you know,
your behaviors or whatever, which I find
really interesting because before you go
to school it was nothing to have a
sexual situation. But now for some
reason there's
an element of conviction that you didn't
want to have sex. But even after you
fell into that, you still hear the
comforting words of Jesus like, "That's
not why, you know, what this is all
about." And that he was still in the
middle of all of that. That
that talks about the intimacy of Jesus
Christ.
For sure, definitely.
So, this is a turning point.
Yes, for sure.
forward, you start making steps towards
yep. Um I know when I was in college at
that time, my one of my close friends, I
remember during my freshman year in
college, freshman year for me was just
really like doing whatever. I was free
bird, doing whatever I felt like doing.
And so, it was my between my freshman
year and sophomore year, that summer,
that's where I had that moment with God,
that dream where I was just like, "All
right, Kezia, we have to stop. You know,
God is clearly near with you know, with
me even in the midst of this situation
that had gone on." And so, by the
following school year, sophomore year,
that's when things really changed where
I started to go to church um
we frequently, like weekly. And also
having a friend who I had from freshman
year, and I noticed that, you know, when
Saturdays or rather like Friday nights,
Saturdays would come about, you know,
she wouldn't do her homework on Friday
nights. Um Saturdays, you know, she'd
watch a sermon. So, it was one of those
things where I would notice like, you
know, what is she doing? Like, why is
she so serious with God? And so, she was
one of those people that really helped
me um to kind of like start my journey
with God and learning to be consistent
and building that relationship. Yeah,
it's so neat too that that God takes you
where you come to him. And and it's like
it's like not this immediate like, "You
got to do this and this and this and
this and this." God just says, "Let's
just work on the relationship." You know
what I mean?
And you start to get this desire that's
brewing inside of you. And and I mean
this this was the same thing for me as
well. I mean, it's just like all of a
sudden I just looked around at my life
and got my just went, "What am I doing?"
I'm addicted to this and I'm into this
and I'm all over the board, all over
with this. And it was like, you know,
God I think very patiently wooed me
back. And that's that that that's what
made me ultimately stick around.
Mhm. Was just how loving he approached
us.
Yeah.
Mhm.
For sure. He's definitely patient. Super
patient. So, you start coming to church.
How do you get involved in the
preaching?
Um I'd say it was one of those things
where even now like I'm still surprised
I'm in this as well with God. Um but it
was one of those things that you know,
people would ask you to um speak on a
certain topic. And so, I know initially
I was a bit more active with the like
singles ministry. Um so, I would help
out with there. We would sometimes host
programs for the parents where we'd say,
"Hey, bring your kids in." So, we'd do
like arts and craft with the with the
children. Um so, it would be a various
amount of things that we would or rather
I would start doing. Um but when it came
to speaking, that was one thing where I
don't even know it was where as like
people would just ask me, "Hey, you
know, can you do this? Um can you do a
Bible study for us? Um even when I went
to I went to Cuba, um that was a miracle
in and of itself because for me to get
to that point, I had gone through a
really bad breakup where I remember
thinking to myself, "You know what? It's
better to just kill myself." But I had
come across um a sermon by Doug
Batchelor and he was just mentioning,
you know, "If you feel suicidal, think
about living your life one more year."
So, I figured, "Okay, you know, I can
live my life one more year and if it you
know, if it doesn't get better in this
next year, I could always end it." And
so, that was my thought process that,
you know, Kezia, since this relationship
has now ended, let this end now be a new
beginning. And so, I was really
intentional in saying, "All right, Lord,
I need your help now." You know, now I'm
learning to be somewhat dependent upon
God. Before it was you know, all these
other things I was doing. But now as I
was, you know, building this
relationship with God, I said, "You
know, Lord, help me to kind of be
progressive in these next few years."
And so, that's where I then started to
see, you know, desires of, you know,
going on mission trips. Um one of those
mission trips was Cuba. I had gone to
Cuba twice. The second time, that's
where I had met Mike. Um what was
interesting was like the the trip um
prior to that second trip to Cuba, the
first trip to Cuba, I remember just
hearing different stories of people, of
the locals in Cuba. And I remember
leaving that trip just saying, "You
know, Lord, you know, what's your story
for me?" And to see how he worked things
out the following year where he was
like, you know, "I need to work on your
own story." That's where I was just
like, "Wow." Because I knew there was a
lot of things I had to unpack. But I
didn't know it was that deep that there
were still things from my childhood that
I didn't work on yet. Isn't that cool
that sometimes God gives you a vantage
point? You know what I mean? Like where
it's like you're in it, you're around
it, you're listening to other preachers.
You think you're there working, but I
often I I think when we get to heaven,
we're going to realize maybe those trips
were thrown together so that God could
reach you.
Yeah. You know what I mean? And he puts
you in that position and it's like all
the angels are working around there to
reach you. And you think you're there
trying to minister to somebody else.
You're getting ministered to. And that's
really how mission trips work. Yeah, it
really is. It's 100%.
were right place, right time.
Yeah. Yeah.
Precisely. So, let me ask this question
and feel free, you don't have to answer
it if you don't want to. Did anything
bad happen on any of these trips or
anything like Were you still tempted?
still tempted for sure. I mean, it was
tricky because
specifically with Cuba, there was no
Wi-Fi. For self For someone who's
addicted to pornography, it's one of
those things where it's just like,
"What am I going to do now?" But the
mind, even though I did not have the
pornography, I know every person is
different. Um some people they need
pornography. Sometimes some people are
able to masturbate without it because of
the amount of things that they have
already done. So, for me I was that
person. That's called the harem in your
mind. I remember even when I first got
into that, like I was collecting people
and I would put them in my memory. And
then, you know, cuz pornography wasn't
available back in the '70s. So, I could
pull these people out and have my
fantasy with them. And I would create
all of these scenarios. I create my own
pornography in my mind. So, I I've heard
it described as a harem in your mind.
And so, you can always go back to that
and recreate that even if you don't have
technology available. For sure. That's
why God says,
"I want to recreate your mind.
I want to give you new thoughts, new
ways of looking at things." You know,
it's like to have the mind of Christ,
right?
Philippians 2:5.
That's right. That's right. The mind of
Christ. I mean, literally just just to
every thought brought into captivity.
Mhm. And of of of him. And that I think
is where God wants to bring all of us in
our Christian walk.
Yeah. So, then speak to this. Um here's
the problem. We see the testimony of a
child that is growing up with all of
these secrets, often looking at
pornography in the home when the parents
aren't there. As a parent, what can you
do? Like what's the step a parent should
make? What do you What do you wish your
mom would have done? Or, you know, how
how how could you have felt comfortable
to be like, "Mom, I'm really struggling
here." Like, give me some advice on
that. I know for the the biggest thing
was just having that level of intimacy,
connection with my parents. I was
lacking that love that I needed, um that
connection. Because of course, anyone
they don't have to be addicted on
pornography. Um
the person goes to um some sort of a
vice because of a broken relationship.
They're trying to fill that void with
something, even if it's bad, even if
it's just um an immediate gratification
because they're not getting that love,
that affection from home. So, because I
wasn't getting that for all those years,
that's why I was so hooked on the porn.
Even with like years later, mid-20s,
realizing like, "Wait, you know, I have
an addiction." I was realizing that I
still didn't let go of the the pain. So,
I know like over this weekend, a friend
of ours was saying that, you know, in
order for you to heal, you have to be
real. So, there was a level of um
realization, the traumas, the pains um
that I was still holding on to for
about, you know, 13, 14 years. I had
never let go of the divorce because, you
know, of the anger that I was still
holding on to. So, I had to recognize
that, you know, the parents' roles are
very important. The affection that they
show, the love, the affirmation, the
consistency, um just them their their
presence, just being there, listening to
a child after they get home from school.
My mom had to work longer hours because
of the divorce, right? So, it was just
one of those things where, you know, I
come home, no one's home. You know, what
am I learning from? You know, I'd turn
on TV. You know, sometimes someone would
come over. So, it was one of those
things where because I I understood, you
know, she had to make that money. You
know, I understand she had to take care
of me as a single parent. But at the
same time, there's you know, that's why
I see the value of why God desired
or rather designed it that it's a
two-parent household. You know, both
parents need to be there. What they are
able to express and to show to their
children is of value. Even if a parent
thinks like, you know, this 5 minutes
means nothing. Like, no, it means the
world that, you know, my parent is there
for me because it shouldn't be I mean,
school and church does play a
big role. But the parents' role, you
know, they are a child's first example
of Christ. And so, over time, you know,
I had to realize that the things I
thought of God, that's not who God is
just because of what my parent has done.
That God is ever forgiving, that he does
forget my sins, that that he does love
me. But it was one of those things that
I had to take my parents, the the image
that I had of God, I had to take that
off from what I got from my parents. So,
that took a while, but definitely a
parent's role is really big. Just the
affirmations, the love, just being
there. They say
a parent truly spends, I think, 15
minutes or less quality time with a
child in a day.
There was an amazing a woman, she came
up to us and we were doing a Q&A with
the pastor's wives, and she looked at us
panel and she goes, "Oh, I understand
everything that you've been through."
And I looked at this woman and I
thought, "Lady, you haven't got a clue."
But then she started to tell us that she
just wanted to see a man naked as a
little kid. And she went up to her
mother and any, you know, good Christian
mother would just be horrified and, you
know, all that's terrible and you
shouldn't have those thoughts and, you
know, don't think about that. But
instead her mother said, "Well, I don't
really have a naked man to show you. I
could ask your father." And the little
kid's like, "No, no, I don't want to
see, you know, father naked." But what
she did is she answered her question
openly and honestly. She didn't shame
her for being curious. What she did is
she gave her a clinical, you know,
example of that enough to satisfy your
curiosity and that was it. Then later as
she was developing, she found a poster
of a naked man in a in a house that they
were cleaning out for a friend and and
and she wadded it up and she hid it from
her brothers and sisters, but she ran to
her mother. She goes, "Look, mother, a
naked man." Like that never even
computed to me. It's like I would never
have taken that to my parents and said,
you know, like shared with them.
it in your pocket and, you know, Yeah,
yeah, yeah, in the backyard. So, so what
was so amazing is that when she showed
her mother again, her mother didn't
freak out. You know, you know, like like
like a lot of parents, I think, just
naturally do thinking, "What have my
child done?" But instead she goes,
"Well, you've always wanted to see a
naked man, there he is." And and then
she
she acknowledged the physical aspect.
She goes, "Didn't I say they have more
muscles? Didn't I say they have more
hair?" And she goes, "Yes, mother." But
what was so
amazing and it brought me to tears. She
said, "But look at his face, what's he
doing?" He says, "Well, he's smiling,
mother." And she said and she said,
"Well, what do you think he's thinking
about?" "I don't know, mother." She
said, "Do you think he's a Christian?
Do you think he's married? Do you think
he holds the car door open for his wife?
Do you think he has children?"
And and what she did is she took it from
the physical, she affirmed all that, but
then she took it to the spiritual. And
what was so amazing, I was sitting there
in tears because I thought, "I wish I
had a parent that I could have gone to
with anything." And I think the most
important comment or answer to your
question is like, "Parents, let your
children come to you with anything and
everything and don't lie to them. Don't
mislead them, but tell them the truth,
whatever that truth is as much as is
necessary to answer their question for
them, but also to be always open and
honest because if you don't have that
conversation with your kids. And now we
don't even have the luxury of waiting
until they're in puberty. If you're not
having that conversation with your kids
before they even go to school or
preschool, you know, when little kids
are being touched and things like that,
you have missed the opportunity and now
you are not the safe source that the
world is a safe source or their friends
are the safe source when it really
should be coming from the parents. And
how sad, Kezia, that that your parents
were so consumed with their own recovery
of their own divorce that here this
child that was their only child and had
no other resources, no brothers or
sisters,
here's this desperate little kid that is
looking for the internet to find some
type of comfort. That breaks my heart.
mean, it was it was interesting because
as I when we when we met in Cuba and
then I had realized, okay, I have an
addiction now, I have to work through
this, I didn't know that God would
permit it that now I had a lot of
unpacking to do. I just thought, okay, I
have an addiction, I'll stop watching
porn, okay, no problem. But as I was
getting serious with God, as I was
really more intentional about my
devotion time with him, he was really
unpacking things where I realized that,
you know,
the traumas, the divorce I hadn't worked
through yet. And even in the midst of
that, I was realizing that I hadn't
forgiven my parents, that there was
still reconciliation that had to take
place. And so when I finally took time
to, you know, apologize to both my
parents, or rather have the opportunity
to now talk to them and really say, you
know, why did you guys leave? You know,
like not rather, but ask my dad, why did
you leave? Why did you think it was
okay? You know, talking to my mom about
it. I remember my mom, she was then
saying, you know, when the divorce
happened, the person who really who
really got the most pain out of it was
you. So, it was one of those things
where I was like, I knew I wasn't crazy
all these years. That the the level of
anger that I was holding onto
subconsciously, you know, it it made
sense why I was doing all these things.
And I mean, thankfully, I've been taking
the time out to really heal from it, to
recover, um to be intentional in saying,
you know, I'm not going to have someone
on the side. I'm going to be serious
about this. I'm going to have filters on
my phones, on my computers, so that I'm
not going to the pornography. But in the
midst of that, really learning, you
know, who is God? Because that's really
been the crux of it all. It's just
recognizing that despite all these bad
things that God has permitted to happen,
that he still is good. That in Romans
8:28, he talks about, you know, all
things work together for good. So, it
was one of those things that it took me
years to recognize like, how is God
still good? Why should I still worship
him when he's permitted me to go through
this divorce? He saw what has happened.
He saw the amount of pain I went
through. Why should I still bow my knees
towards him? But it took years for me to
recognize that God knows what he's
doing, that he was not surprised by what
he allowed to happen. And isn't it neat
that you should be able to come to God
with everything. Just like you should
come to your earthly parents. You should
you should be able to have that kind of
connection. And and and God can handle
it. I mean, he can handle anything. But
I thought those thoughts in my head were
way too dirty to share with a holy
righteous God.
Yeah, I
that was really difficult for me to
learn that that when I really started to
get angry and start, you know, blurting
out all this stuff that was in my head
or whatever, that was when God said,
"Great, Mike, now we're starting to get
real. Now we can really start working
with that." And what I think is really
amazing is that as you
were reaching out to God and addressing
all of that anger,
you you talk in your story about this
one moment. It's like,
Kezia, you're a beautiful woman and yet
you thought you were ugly. And how God
revealed to you that that to him you are
beautiful. But what what evades me so
much is that how you didn't know that.
Like like every time that you were
either giving yourself away sexually,
you were losing maybe your own
self-worth or your self-value. But how
is it that this poor little girl grows
up thinking that she's ugly?
We are always our worst critic.
I mean, of course.
I think what happened was just knowing
that, um
with all the things that were going on
at home, to hear certain things being
said, like, you know,
something in regards to like your skin
color or your hair texture. So, of
course, now I'm just thinking, okay, you
know, I'm ugly. But it wasn't until so I
I went through the moment where went to
Cuba, then I went to this conference and
then by the following year,
I was really desiring to have a full
detox. I'm like a I went to a a health
retreat because I have eczema and I was
just like, you know, I'd really love a
full physical detox, a nice cleanse. But
I didn't know that that retreat would
really serve as a holistic time of
healing where it wasn't just a physical
cleanse, it was also the mental
cleansing, the spiritual cleansing.
Because in the midst of that, you know,
on the first five days, we were having
it was just like a straight juice fast.
Just lots of smoothies, juices, very
clean. And so, of course, when you're
not eating, your mind is really clear to
now hear from God. And so in the midst
of that, that's where I started to just
break down by like day two or three and
I was just like, Lord is just bringing
things to my mind from childhood. I
didn't work through things. And so I
remember the person who was my what do
you call like my counselor, she was just
mentioning, you know, to stop running
from counseling and to really just get
help and to stop doing it like stagnant.
Just just be consistent. And I just
broke down because I was just like, I
don't know what to do now. Like I'm
overwhelmed with everything that I've
been doing. I've been doing this for
years. How can I now stop? Because it's
not just saying I stopped watching porn.
There's also the thoughts that now
occur. It's having to realize how do I
now live this new life? And so in the
midst of that, I was just recognizing
the biggest thing I had to do was to to
actually go for counseling. So, I I
spoke with someone and the person had
mentioned,
you know, to write down everything,
every person that has pained you. And I
was just like, what? Like why would I
write down every person that pained me?
Like I would not do that. But it it took
me a while, but the the directions was,
you know, to to make a list,
write down the person's name, write
down, um that pain, write down the lies
you believed from that pain, and then
write down,
a prayer to go against that lie, and
then also a Bible verse against that.
So, I had like 10 different situations
that occurred over life. And then I
realized that there was a there was a
there were two things that were in
common in the midst of all these 10
pains. It was that I believed that I was
ugly, and then the second one was my
abandonment issues, like to feeling
neglected. And so that's where it it
really showed me that the the reason why
I'm doing all these things is based off
of something from a childhood. And even
from the lies, like it just so happened
to be that in regards to me feeling like
I was ugly, it just so happened to be
that my dad, even though, you know, he's
not necessarily big in Christianity per
se, he loves the story of Job. And so he
picked my name from the book of Job.
After Job had lost everything, Job was
now restored. He got a new he had new
children. And of the children,
one of the the daughter's names was
Kezia. And so it just so happened to be
that that verse with Job 42:14 and 15,
it mentions that Kezia, you know, was
one of the fairest daughters of all the
land. So, it was one of those things
where I was like, "Oh, Lord, thank you.
I'm beautiful in your sight." It was
just an you know, an affirmation from
God. I, you know, I don't have to wait
on anyone to tell me anything. But just
recognizing how much God views me. And
so that's where I had to realize the I
had to let God's thoughts define me.
Just to not, you know, be so consumed
with all the things I'm I've gone
through, which were factual, which
occurred, but it just to recognize that,
you know, this is not too hard for God,
that he's able to heal me. But it took
time and intentionality and really
surrendering and just being honest with
God and letting him know like this is
how I feel, but he's just also letting
me know, but this is what I think of you
and this is who you are. But it took
time. It It took time. Wow. So, I got to
play catch up here cuz you brought up,
man, so many points. But to answer your
question about, you know, someone can be
beautiful. People can look at them and
say that they're beautiful, but they
themselves may not feel that. Um I think
that is one of the major roles of the
father in the household to affirm the
daughter. Could you just unpack that for
a minute cuz
you know, because this this is so pow-
I'm glad you brought it to that because,
you know, we have more single parents
now raising children than we do dual
parents and and the father in in media,
the father in the home has been so
minimized and marginalized. There's a
stupid joke, a really stupid joke, at a
men's conference and it said this kid
comes home and he and he and he brags to
his mommy and says, "Mom, I got a I got
a um part in the play." And she goes,
"Really, what is it?" And he goes,
"Well, I play the father." And she goes,
"You go back to that school and you tell
them you want a speaking part." Oh. I
mean, the whole point about that is how
we have lost that aspect of the home,
that we need fathers that that do that,
you know, and and I say this thing about
how every girl needs a father that will
bounce her on her knee and tell her that
she's a princess and that she that she's
precious and that he'll protect her. And
how sad that, you know, very few now
families have that father image in the
home and even if he's there, many times
he's absent.
And imagine the burden that that puts on
the single mothers in the churches that
have children that are desperate for a a
masculine image and affirmation to say
that you are precious and that and and
beautiful to them. So, I think there's
so much more to be shared about that and
and how like the enemy to destroy the
father in the home so that people grow
up like like what you've been exposed to
and thinking that your only validation
is in whether people find you sexually
desirable or not. You also brought up
Job. Uh Jo- Job's story is just uh
there's so much in there for each of us.
Um but talking about uh how we can come
to God with anything, you know, our
dirtiest, our greatest, whatever the
case. I mean, Job, think if you remember
his conversation with God. He's like,
"Why this? Why that?" There's so much
chaos in the world. He's like letting
loose. And he was able to have that
conversation with God and yet he still
called perfect man.
You know, God was there to listen to him
and have that conversation. I don't
think we should ever be afraid. And if
it's if we are, I think it's because we
need to address the lies that we've been
telling ourselves that we've been told.
Address the lies.
And the next thing, as I said, I need to
catch up, but um you were asking about
about parents and and how they can talk
to their kids. Another thing that came
up in my mind, I mean, you guys brought
up so many amazing points, which are so
true, but also for parents to lead the
conversation through asking questions to
their kids. Um so, to see where their
head is at or to see how they respond to
certain things. The story that you you
shared about the mom and her and her
daughter wanting to see a naked man. I
mean, she just she was in control of
that whole conversation and asking
questions. You know, I would come to in
my home, I always felt open to come to
my mom about everything. Problem was, as
a child, I didn't always know what to
ask, you know, or just some certain
things are just not in my mind to be
able to ask. And then I would get into a
situation and just like, "Oh man." I
would come to my mom.
She was like, "Oh yeah, this is what you
do." I was like, "Man, like why didn't
you tell me before?" And her response
is, "Oh, because you didn't ask." And
I'm like, "Mom,
like how am I supposed to know to ask
this?" And I get on that on her about
that all the time, but we're fine. But I
think that's super important for the
parent to ask a question, not just wait
for the kids to come and ask them. Yeah.
But the reaction of the parents, I
think, as well. Like,
if we freak out and negatively react,
you know what I mean? I guarantee you
that kid's going to be like, "Oh, this
is what happens if I mention this." You
know what I mean?
So, yeah, if something at school, you
know, happens or whatever, like I I can
remember
my brother-in-law coming and sharing
with with my wife something that
happened to his child at daycare. His
child was, I think, five or something
like this at the time. And his child
came and, you know, said, "Oh, one of
the other boys did this and this and
this to me." You know what I mean? As a
parent, it's like hard not to be like,
"What?"
You know, you want to just roll over to
the daycare and be like, "We're going to
regulate this whole place."
Regulate.
That was a '90s term.
Somehow I missed it.
But but, you know, I think I think we
need to be able to react in a loving,
calm manner and and to me, I keep going
back to that's how God reacted with me.
Can I jump in because, you know
something? That little kid that was that
was um exposed to that stuff in that
daycare,
you can't stop that. That's going to
happen no matter where you are in your
Christian experience, no matter how hard
you try to protect your children, but
your reaction to it can change the whole
event. Like like to be, you know, like
if you would have had the ability to go
to your mother and say, "This is what
happened in daycare." Your mother could
have helped you process and said, "You
know, it was unfortunate that that
happened. This isn't what God wants for
you. Those are your private places and
nobody should ever touch you because you
are a princess and you're royalty and,
you know, then the kid is able to kind
of go move from that and just say,
"Okay, this is an acceptable behavior.
This happened, it's in my past, but it
doesn't have to form my future." And
because you didn't have that, look at
how it ended up doing the snowball
effect in your And also, like to to even
bring it further when you're a teenager,
too. You know, if your child, let's say
you catch your child watching
pornography, if it's like freak out
mode, super embarrassment, you know,
like, you know, shut everything down and
tell everybody, you know, like, "My kid
has a problem." You may cause that child
to go more darker into the closet, where
it's like, you know, they're just going
to be more careful down the road.
Rather than that approach, sitting down
and saying, "This is not God's design.
This is the reason for this." And, you
know, to lovingly say, you know, you
know, "I'm here for you, you know, and
there's an issue."
There's always a difference when you're
told to do something versus when you
decide to do something. You know, so
when when a parent just overreacts and,
you know, it's like, "Oh, you've told me
not to do this or or you've created a
rule.
This is a desire. Okay, I'm going to
break it now. I'm going to keep it from
you." But if you explain it and then the
child understands, it's like, "Okay, I'm
deciding not to do this again." It's
more lasting.
Because it's theirs.
Wow, this is good stuff, guys. Like,
this should be like a three- or
four-hour show. Wait, there's more.
She's got more.
I want you to tell them about that
Sunday that you came to my sister's
house cuz she was blocking. She I'll
tell you what, let's save it for the
post show. Okay. Okay. So,
What's the post show, Scotty? Tell them
what the post show For those that help
support our ministry cuz we put out a
lot of content for free. So, people that
support our ministry and really help us
out on a month-to-month basis, we like
to give you something extra, something
that you just can't get. So, we do that
through Patreon. If you want to hear
more of Keziah's story and some of the
other
little details,
jump over to Patreon and there's a lot
of really cool perks there, but that's
kind of our way of just saying thank you
to the people that help keep the lights
on and the cameras rolling on on our
place here. So,
you know, any last thoughts before we
kind of close down, you guys? I know
we've been throwing thoughts all over,
but I do want to mention that your
testimony is like we we kind of talked
about this already, but like your
testimony just shows that God is not
trying to keep something fun away, like,
"Oh, Christians, you can't have sex or
watch porn or whatever." It's like it
just shows
that God's design is perfect. He
designed it this way. It's only become
what it is because of all the perversion
and all the twisting, but when you enter
into these situations, sex before
marriage, you have you bring in kids in
the world that aren't even wanted and
then you have fathers that distance
themselves and they create a being who
grows up without a father and and trying
to fill these voids with all these, you
know, promiscuous lifestyles and drugs
and everything.
So, you know, just to maybe address like
for people who think, "Man, why can't I
do this? You know, why is God keeping
all this fun stuff from me?" It just
shows, you know, it's a testimony to
his perfect design. I think the devil is
a master at making
hurtful things look fun.
Things that are like enticing, like, you
know, I mean, he could make eating trash
be something beautiful. And and the the
opposite is so true. If we adhere to
God's principles, there's true
fulfillment in that. There's true love
that that God wants. And and the devil's
like, "No, lust is love." You know what
I mean? The idea of taking something
from someone else and, you know, that's
the that's the idea, but that's just a
total lie. It's really like if you
adhere by what God is saying
in a marriage context, that's when sex
should be the most, you know, enjoyed
and everything.
That that's going to give you
fulfillment in your life. And that's
what we see actually in the studies.
There's study after study after study
that say if you have only one partner,
those are the most fulfilled sexual
relationships. And, you know, the more
partners you go down the road, you can
see the graph. It goes down. The the the
more variety of things that the world
quote quote unquotes is like, "This is
fun. Orgies are fun." Whatever. All
these things is what you should engage
in. Look at how you walk away from that
empty, hurt, and even deeper into it.
I'd actually I'd like to encourage
parents. And I'm not a parent, but
listening to you guys, you know, the
pressure is on, it seems like. Um but
it's good pressure. It's good pressure.
Yeah, necessary.
But um I'm sure it's easy to get
overwhelmed and things like that, but
just to remember, you know, who is in
control and who you can always go to.
And in praying for not only your
children, but for praying for the Holy
Spirit to give you the words to say, to
have your kids ask the right questions.
I mean, that's what the Holy Spirit,
that's his work, to impress upon the
heart and the mind. So, um we just want
to encourage each and every one of you
and know that we're praying for you on
this show, um in our personal lives,
we're always praying for for the
outpouring of the Holy Spirit.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Well, thank you guys for watching. What
a blessing to have you guys on our show.
Thank you for coming. Um as always, if
you are new to our channel, we love to
handle topics like this that, you know,
just needs to shed some light on it on
on the darkness that we all have gotten
ourselves into. And uh you know, like
our video, subscribe. If you know other
people that are struggling with a a
topic like this, um feel free to share
this video with other people. Post it on
Facebook. Share our videos. They're
meant to be shared. And uh we just want
to thank you Patreon donors for helping
donate to this ministry so that we can
keep doing these kind of projects. And
uh we always want to hear from you. So,
leave a comment, leave a thumbs up, and
uh God bless you guys. We'll see you
next Friday.
Bye.